today's question i want to talk about is
what are the four
most important customers every
startup entrepreneur has
so i'm patrick with david your host of
valuetainment weekly and we are
currently at the
me cancun resort which is an incredible
resort they have
here about 60 of our friends hanging out
we were poolside yesterday and one of
our entrepreneurs
brought up a question about you know who
are my real
customers i think one of the mistakes a
lot of uh times we make is
we either think only our clients are our
customers and sometimes people think
only their agents are their customers
but there's a lot more customers that an
entrepreneur
has and i said you know from having been
in a
business for quite some time and
learning from all the mistakes
i made where i only thought i had one
customer at the beginning of my career
i have come to realize every
entrepreneur has four customers four
customers so number one
your salesmen are your king because
they're the ones going out there doing a
marketing for you
so whether it's your agent your real
estate agent your pharmaceutical
salesman your
car salesman whoever it is that's
selling your product for you marketing
your product for you
he is a customer of yours you need to
take care of your sales department
because without them they're not able to
communicate
with your clients your clients are the
ones that are purchasing from you
whatever your product and service may be
they're also your customers so we have
agents or
salesmen and then we have clients and
those are your buying customers they buy
your product they buy your service they
buy the house
they buy policy they're your number two
customers so you have your sales force
then you have your clientele and number
three number three which is the one that
gets very little attention sometimes
is your support team i'm talking your
assistant your employees
people that do this stuff behind the
scenes that nobody sees
those folks who are doing their part
working very hard diligently
but they don't necessarily are the face
of the company you have no idea how
important of a role they play
and your number four customers that you
have number four customers that you have
is one that we kind of feel entitled to
that they're supposed to do whatever we
want them to do and that's your partners
partners i mean if i'm a loan officer i
have
lenders i use b of a wells fargo or
chase or whatever these companies are
these are my partners
if you're a company that sells shoes and
one of your
companies you're dealing with a certain
brand they're a partner of yours
you got to take care of them and once
you learn how to work with all of these
foreign you put that in front
force your clientele who are buying
number three is your supporting cast and
number four is your partner
and you find a way to make sure each one
of them
are satisfied accordingly you're not
going to please everybody but you're
working you're you're having you're
being intentional
about finding a way on working with
these guys you're going to have better
results long-term retention is going to
be higher people are going to want to
work with you longer they're going to
want to partner with you longer they're
going to want to be
part of your team longer because of the
fact that you realize how important of a
role
those four different customers play in
the success of your business
it's my message of the week to you and
please be sure to subscribe to this
channel and comment on the bottom